all construction on the southern border
guess what it's now underway according
to a report Washington Examiner look at
this miles of desperately needed
brand-new steel barriers are under
construction all along the Rio Grande
Valley this portion of the wall was
funded with federal money previously
negotiated by the Trump administration
nobody seems to report that we've also
repaired a lot of the bad walls that
were out there and there is new
construction now meanwhile this garbage
deal that I've been telling you about
out of Washington which allocates a
measly additional one point three seven
five billion dollars for wall
construction well that has not yet been
signed by the President as a matter of
fact nobody in the White House has seen
any language in the bill none so let's
be frank it's not nearly enough money
Washington lawmakers the swamp creatures
they have once again let we the people
the American people down this is a swamp
compromise now let me make some
predictions based on what the president
is saying publicly because I love the
press they they love to speculate had it
handed to get his information all right
we know this is a president that keeps
his promises and he goes at the speed of
Trump and if you watch every speech if
you actually listen to Donald Trump's
words you know especially you people in
the hate Trump media you psychos he
Telegraph's he's saying exactly what
he's planning to do you're too stupid to
listen watch this so much crime comes in
through our southern border
illegal immigration provides a lucrative
cash flow to put it mildly lucrative to
some of the most dangerous criminal
organizations on the planet these deadly
cartels flood our cities with narcotics
that kill thousands of our citizens
ruined families they use fear
intimidation and violence to get their
way there is only one moral course of
action to put these ruthless criminal
cartels out of business and out of
business fast
I will never waver from my sacred duty
to defend this nation and its people we
will get the job done
all right he's saying he's going to get
the job done let me make a prediction
let's base it on what you just heard and
what we've witnessed the last two years
the president's going to find the way to
get the money now look at this bill one
point three seven five billion two not
enough but it will keep the ball and the
project moving along assuming we haven't
seen the language there's no poison pill
or restrictions in there thrown in by a
swamp creature in the last minute that
says you can't build a wall with the
money that happens I don't think the
president will sign that bill in that
case you probably move to a short-term
CR and the Congress creatures will go
back to do the crappy work that they
usually do and then if they get it right
he'll sign that bill but let's assume
that they get it right that in other
words he gets one point three seven five
million a billion for the wall now
well that prevents a government shutdown
that's a good thing but in order to meet
our borders and our security needs the
president has stated publicly not just
to Sean Hannity that he will also tap
into hundreds of millions at least 900
million but I'm told the number is much
higher other discretionary funds that he
can direct that money directly to the
wall which that brings us to two or
three billion dollars again in the
interim and it sounds like what he's
saying is he's going to simultaneously
declare a national emergency to free up
billions more now the hate Trump media
if that happens they're going to feign
moral indignation outrage hysteria will
will break out meanwhile they'll say had
it Hannity no well because I've listened
to him and he's telling you the entire
time what he's going to do Donald Trump
quote I will add whatever I have to add
to build the wall president tweeting I
am getting almost 23 billion for border
security now that money the twenty three
billion he's talking about that can be
spent on everything else but the wall
but if he declares a national emergency
or uses the law which we've been signing
on this Pro
Grahame u.s. code 284 well we know what
the Democrats are gonna do they're gonna
immediately run to the courts that
little judge shopping they'll find a
liberal activist judge somewhere in
California or anywhere in the ninth
circuit they will lose the president
will lose the first round go to the
ninth circuit he'll lose the second
round but in the interim he still gets
one point three seven five billion so he
continues the project and the other
funds continues the project and I
believe when it gets to the Supreme
Court he's gonna win and this Supreme
Court is gonna have to take this case
considering let's see it's a
constitutional question about his role
as commander in chief
it's about separation of powers it's
about national security and just a side
note all you in the media I don't know
why everyone's been obsessed Hannity's
predicting this hey that's what I'm
predicting is going to happen because I
actually listened to the publicly stated
words of the President so keep
speculating nobody in the media has any
idea of who my sources are who they're
not and who I talk to who I don't talk
to and I will not reveal my sources
and all these hate Trump media outlets
they put they all pretend they're
they're unbiased that they're they're
journalists well I don't claim to be a
journalist we do journalism what we say
about being a talk-show host where like
the whole newspaper now we do straight
news when there's war straight news on
whether straight news unimportant you
know incidences that are happening like
Ferguson when that was happening or or
Baltimore and then we give a lot of
opinion so where the news page the
editorial page the opinion page we even
do gossip and sports like tonight for
example Tim Tebow's on so we're like the
whole newspaper that's what we do
freedom of the press but we identify
what we do now we do our own research
like we did with vetting Obama like we
do on the deep state we do
investigations we bring you news and
information you won't hear or see
anywhere else an opinion you won't get
anywhere else but all these hate Trump
news people that claim to be journalists
now they're really editor
writers and ones that make up a lot of
BS at the same time so tonight when it
comes to building the wall whatever has
to be done the president's saying will
be done not for political reasons but
for the safety and the security of all
Americans he sees this rightly so as a
life-and-death issue but don't just take
my word for it maybe some of the people
in these fake news channels maybe they
should start speaking to angel moms and
dads maybe a woman like Maureen Maloney
her son Matthew killed by a drunk
driving illegal immigrant from Ecuador
you got that Senator Menendez he was
upset that illegal immigrants could
actually be classified as criminals that
they get caught drunk driving and
yesterday Maloney urged President Trump
to hold strong in this fight for the
border wall sadly she is among thousands
of our fellow Americans whose lives have
been ripped apart permanent separation
by violent criminals because we have
open borders that have entered this
country illegally in the past two years
alone ice arresting illegal immigrants
who were accused or convicted of four
thousand murder homicide charges carnage
from illegal drugs ninety percent of the
heroin crossing that southern border is
even worse every single week three
hundred Americans are dying from heroin
overdoses almost all of which traffic
across that border now that's why
Americans are overwhelmingly backing up
the President and its plan to secure the
border brand-new Fox polls sixty six
percent of Americans approve of the
president's efforts you Republicans in
the House and Senate you may just want
to follow his lead good politics
according to Gallup the president's
overall poll numbers are up a whopping
seven points since the government
shutdown he had his highest number fifty
two percent on the Rasmussen poll
earlier this week he filled an arena in
El Paso Texas look at that and oh that's
inside the arena am i correct yes then
he had thousands and thousands of others
outside the arena nobody in the media
talks about this what other president
got those types of crowds now some on
the Left they try and pretend
the president has no support at all I've
never seen a president with more support
look at late-night loser Stephen Colbert
himself just last week watch this
Trump's inaugural committee raised a
record 107 million dollars which was
double the previous record set by Barack
Obama what was all that money for I mean
obviously they didn't need it for crowd
control yeah let's show the picture
before the inauguration ever took place
so are your audience is stupid enough
that they'll probably believe your crap
maybe Colbert needs to attend a trump
rally maybe he will see the unbelievable
enthusiasm people standing for hours and
hours and hours outside in the cold and
the rain and then standing for the
entire time the president speaking
supporting his agenda which brings us
tonight to our Hannity watch on what is
the radical socialist take over the
Democratic Party now the president is
promoting freedom low taxes national
security and strength uninformed social
socialists extremists they are now
steering the ship at the DNC in a pretty
big way a kind of scary way they look at
freshmen congresswoman Alexandria Acacio
Cortes and says the world's gonna end in
12 years now leading the way she is the
chief spokesman leader for the
Democratic Party and has some background
look at the new leader of the left take
a look Medicare for all would save the
American people a very large amount of
money why aren't we incorporating the
cost of all the funeral expenses of
those who died because they can't afford
access to health care but when it comes
to tax cuts for billionaires and when it
comes to unlimited war we seem to be
able to be to invent that numb that
money very easily we look at these
figures and we say oh unemployment is
low everything is fine right well
unemployment is low because everyone has
two jobs I need to occupy every Airport
need to occupy every border we need to
occupy every ice office if we work our
butts off to make sure that we take back
all three chambers of Congress rather
all three chambers of government the
presidency
Senate and the house you use the term
the occupation of Palestine mmm what did
you mean by that
oh I think it what I meant is like the
the settlements just last year we gave
the military a seven hundred billion
dollar attack a budget increase which
they didn't even ask for and we're like
the world is going to end in 12 years if
we don't address climate change and your
biggest issue is your your biggest issue
is how are we gonna pay for it no I
think it is a green dream and I think
that it is it is you know I don't
consider that to be a dismissive term I
think it's a great term hmm I guess it's
no surprise that congresswoman Acacio
Cortez's green New Deal has now become a
nationwide laughingstock except for the
fact Democrats are really serious about
this insane piece of legislation take it
seriously
2020 presidential hopefuls are literally
tripping over each other to support the
green New Deal make no mistakes
Democrats want to radically reshape this
country into a little socialist echo
utopia that will promise everything and
deliver nothing but catastrophe and
poverty and if you're wondering what a
socialist utopia looks like well this
new Green Deal
oh no more oil no more natural gas no
more nuclear no more airplanes no more
gas-powered cars no more gas powered
ovens no more cows because of flatulence
government promised paid leave medically
paid vacation oh now they wrecked high
school and K through 12 so now they're
gonna wreck college education free for
all healthy food for all government
forced renovation of every building in
America and the name of
energy-efficiency government paid for
high-speed rail connecting every city in
America we won't have airplane so I
guess we'll have high-speed trains to
Australia and Asia and Europe and
they're gonna guarantee income to every
single person even those unwilling to
work Wow and a retirement plan but
believe it or not there's even more
madness now we'd be here all night if I
listed at all so look at the side
your screen and here's the kicker the
green New Deal is calling for this to
happen in ten years and the world is
going to be over in 12 years according
to Acacio cortez if we don't act on
twitter today she said passing the green
New Deal is a life or death issue well
in a way she's right because if this
ever happens in this country the
American dream that has created more
wealth more prosperity than any other
country on the face of this earth
it's over government will take over
every single industry the healthcare
industry no private health care the
energy industry they will give you that
kraid cradle to grave womb to tomb
promise they'll tell you what car you
can drive where you can travel what you
can eat and even how you cook it your
more notably in order to try and pay for
that in Saturday mother government well
they'll own your paycheck from each
according to their ability to each
according to their needs
right congresswoman and I know you watch
the show and let's not forget about
those who would be impacted first
Airlines 707 hundred thousand employees
goodbye
over 10 million people old their jobs to
oil and the gas industry SIA millions
more serving roles related to those two
major industries promoting this stupid
deal Democrats they're actively actively
called for tens of millions of Americans
to lose high-paying jobs and it's only
going to get bigger we have two
pipelines on the line and we opened
Anwar we're the number one world
producer surpassing Saudi Arabia and
Russia for the first time in 70 years
and all the high-paying career jobs that
will be available for people look at
this Fox News poll twenty five percent
of Americans have a favorable view of
socialism it promises everything and
never delivers historically a thing and
another freshman Democratic lawmaker is
making news for also all the wrong
reasons and that's congresswoman Omar
embroiled in a serious controversy over
her constant stream of hatred and
anti-semitic remarks and she is since
issued an apology on one of the remarks
but her bad behavior on Capitol Hill is
not going away
look at this from earlier today a
hearing with the
relations new special envoy for
Venezuela Elliott Abrams watch this
doozy I fail to understand why members
of this committee or the American people
should find any testimony that you give
today to be truthful if I can respond to
that it wasn't a question that was not
that was not a question that was my I
reserve the right to my time yes or no
do you think that massacre was a
fabulous achievement that happened under
our watch that is a ridiculous question
about yes or no no I know I'll take it
as a yes and as of today yeah that
extremist holds all of our very
important committee assignments so let's
recap the week for Democrats one member
of Congress reading an anti-semitic
conspiracy theory about Jewish money
bozo O'Rourke said the walls killed
people three top Democrats in Virginia
refusing to resign two over blackface
controversies one over yeah
rape allegations and sexual assault
multiple top Democrats supporting a bill
that would turn America into a socialist
disaster eco state multiple twenty
twenty candidates for the Democrats
calling for tax increases and government
stealing one still apologizing for
faking her ethnicity Spartacus himself
police calling for an end to all meat
consumption what a week to think the
race is just getting started well full
coverage on all of this later first we
turn Hannity watch on the deep state now
while we sound the alarm Democrats are
suspiciously silent on the increasing
evidence of corruption abuse of power
inside the FBI and the Justice
Department like the alleged quid pro quo
agreement between the FBI the Clinton
State Department we have new documents
obtained by Judicial Watch the top FBI
brass including Lisa paged who was well
with Peter struck they're scrambling in
the run up to the 2016 election about
evidence of an offer from a Clinton ally
X State Department of
Patrick Kennedy to have the bureau
reduce the classification that they
found on Anthony Weiner's laptop a
Clinton email in exchange will boost FBI
personnel abroad but just change the
classification so she doesn't have to go
to jail
we'll have a report coming up later in
the show